it's great to welcome to the program
today Elizabeth Kolbert who's a writer
for The New Yorker and also author of
the book the sixth extinction which I
read a couple of months ago now I would
say really fascinating book Elizabeth's
and interestingly you know this week we
actually got a report from biodiversity
international which is saying we are in
the midst of a sixth mass extinction
which is going right along with the
subject matter of the book so for people
who don't know what we're talking about
what were the first five extinctions why
are we already on number six how did you
first sort of come to know of this topic
and start writing about it and
researching the book well the first
question what were the what were the
previous five that goes back a long ways
we're talking about basically the whole
history of multicellular life which is
very roughly speaking a half half a
billion years and during that time the
fossil record just shows us that there
have been five major mass extinctions
the most famous of which is is the fifth
the end Cretaceous extinction which is
the event that did in the dinosaurs and
there's a pretty broad scientific
consensus that that was caused by an
asteroid impact so the idea that we're
in the sixth and so these events are
events that were during which the
diversity of life on planet Earth
plunged very suddenly once again in
geological terms and to say that we're
in the sixth so in each of those events
roughly a three-quarters of the species
on earth were lost and if we are
currently and another one that's
obviously a very very big deal and the
reason that many scientists think we are
in the midst of another one or if we're
on the verge or another one is simply
that extinction rates are extremely high
really astronomically I compare to
what's called the background rate which
is just the rate that would you expect
species to go extinct in sort of the
ordinary course of geological time and
the way I got on this subject
I was interested in what was being
called the amphibian crisis so a lot of
amphibians and pinions or frogs and
toads and salamanders a lot of enduring
populations around the world were
crashing and people were trying to
figure out why and in the process of
reporting that story investigating that
story I came across this idea that we're
now in the midst of another mass
extinction and that just struck me as
extraordinary that you know I didn't
know about this and it seemed to me that
that everyone ought to know about it and
in the course of researching the book I
mean you mentioned the the amphibian
crisis and that took you to South
America for part of your research we
also interviewed Ken caldera who you
joined near Australia but at the Great
Barrier Reef how long was the entire
process of doing all the research for
this book including all these different
trips that you you participated in well
the whole process took more than forty
or four and a half years as a from sort
of conception to handie and a manuscript
so it's a pretty long process and it
seems that in a number of these
different circumstances you ended up
sort of camping out in relatively
precarious situations were you much of
an outdoors person before doing this
project I mean how foreign were some of
those environments you found yourself in
well I I mean I certainly have been on a
lot of hiking trips and camping trips
but when you go to some of these places
that are very remote you really need to
know what you're doing and I was really
fortunate and to be able to go at people
who really knew what they were doing
because I would not have you know simply
found my way and a lot of them but they
were amazing places to get to you know
the Amazonian rainforest and the cloud
forests of Peru and the Great Barrier
Reef reef and and and just some of the
most spectacular places on earth was
there a particularly shocking moment in
terms of you know as people read through
the book they will they will learn about
the frogs in South America the problems
with coral reefs dead bats
I mean there's there's sort of different
aspects to this issue that that you
touch on to paint the picture was there
something you personally experienced
that was sort of like the most shocking
moment in terms of what you were
witnessing in person during the process
of researching this book well one of the
sort of interesting paradoxes of
researching a book is that I went to
these amazing places many of them very
remote but the point of being there was
was looking for how human human impacts
some of which were very obvious and some
of which were you know pretty pretty
subtle and had to be teased out through
you know chemical analysis but I think
that what did really one of the most
amazing places I went during this
reporting of the book was the Great
Barrier Reef and the predictions for the
future of the Great Barrier Reef were
very dire and actually since I was there
so I guess you could say this is not in
the course of reporting the book but
very shortly thereafter there have been
several major bleaching events on the
Great Barrier Reef so that's when the
water temperatures get too high and a
lot of the coral turns white and if it
were temperature stay high the corals
die and if you look you can go online
and find video of people just taking
these small plans like over the Great
Barrier Reef I'm shooting down and you
see vast expanses of the leaves have
turned white and there's so there's been
several major bleaching events since I
was on the Great Barrier Reef and the
future of the river which I
unfortunately sort of outlined in the
book just based on on modelling and
predictions is starting to really come
true and that's just - as I say just in
a few years that's really really
sobering and pretty horrifying thought
because the Great Barrier Reef which
when I saw it was already you know had
been severely you know damaged
this was is was still a spectacular
place full full of life
certainly you know human impact is one
of the biggest themes that goes
throughout discussions of the sixth
extinction
can you talk to our audience a little
bit about I mean I think most people
sort of have an understanding of fossil
fuel use and the way that impacts our
planet trash in the oceans is a big deal
deforestation and that's also connected
to your book the sixth extinction what
are some of the other areas here that we
should be thinking about in terms of how
humans on the planet are impacting what
what you write about and what we're
talking about when we talk about the
sixth extinction well I look at I mean
there are there are multiple drivers of
extinction right now you mentioned some
of the big ones the climate is changing
so many many species are are on the move
looking for ways to to sort of follow
the climate that they are used to which
means in many cases moving towards the
poles or moving up elevational gradients
another big issue that's potentially a
very large driver of extinction and I
think one of the big ones that really
hangs over this whole issue though it
does not get the kind of press that
climate change does is what's known as
ocean acidification and that's sort of
the often referred to or sometimes
referred to as global warns equally evil
twin and what happens when we burn
fossil fuels we dump a lot of co2 into
the atmosphere is that very quickly a
lot of that co2 gets absorbed in the
surface waters of the ocean it dissolves
in the ocean and when co2 dissolves in
water it forms an acid carbonic acid
it's you drink it you know if you have a
Coke or if you had some clogs though
today you drank carbonic acid so it's a
weak acid but if you if you add enough
of it to the oceans you you change their
chemistry and that's what we're doing
and when people when scientists look
back at the fossil record and they look
at moments where the oceans became worth
more acidified those are often really
really bad moments for for life in
general so that's a very big issue
hanging over planet Earth's right now
and that one also seems to be you know
from our conversation with Ken caldera
about this some of the so-called I don't
wanna use the word solutions but actions
that could be taken to mitigate other
aspects of climate change would not
really help ocean acidification in other
words like solar engineering in order to
deflect some sunlight to deal with the
warming component would not even touch
the co2 in the oceans aspect he talked
about you know sort of like antacids in
large bodies of water but that
practically speaking that doesn't really
seem to be a great idea that seems to be
a particularly tough one yes and I think
that that that is why you know that one
of the scary things about or one of the
many many scary things about you know
this world that we're creating is that
there is the potential to do things that
would help you know us ourselves our
species but that would be really really
devastating for other species many many
other species and I think there's really
a question which is very difficult to
answer in the abstract about whether you
can you know trash marine lights ocean
life and whether human Humanity can
really do that without a severe severe
penalty and disruption to human life so
I I think people need to be much more
aware of these issues I don't think we
have any of the answers but we're
certainly not we're certainly treading
on very very dangerous into a very
dangerous territory the book is the
sixth extinction we've been speaking
with the book's author Elizabeth Kolbert
will pause our conversation there and
continue tomorrow we're continuing our
conversation with Elizabeth Kolbert
who's a writer for The New Yorker also
author of the book the sixth extinction
in the first part of the interview we
talked a lot about the sort of facts on
the ground and the research you
participated in in writing the book I'd
like to talk a little bit with you about
sort of the political situation around
climate change and extinction is part of
the problem in your mind that as you
mentioned
we have a sixth extinction apparently
happening here very quickly in
geological time which of course for the
scope of a human life is still a very
very long time is that part of why it
can be difficult to really build
consensus and take action on the broader
issue of climate change because when you
have elections every two or four years
limited resources and people wanting to
get reelected the timeline that a lot of
these things are happening on doesn't
really lend itself to the type of
conversations we should be having yes I
think that's definitely part of it but
it doesn't it's not entirely adequate
because there are obviously a lot of
issues that we do deal with that are
multi even multi you know certainly
multi decade and even multi generational
in scope and somehow we have managed to
do them so climate change seems to
present us with almost a uniquely
dangerous situation and many people have
tried to you know come at this for
different reasons why is it that's
something that is really you know
potentially and I don't think I'm
exaggerating here an existential threat
to humanity but we seem unable to take
really even the first baby steps towards
trying to solve it in fact you have a
lot of people out there and many of them
now occupy the highest offices in
American government who simply deny that
there's a problem now we are so far
beyond the point where you could deny
that there's a problem and I think I
believe that people increasingly see
this just around them they feel it
around them I'm now sitting you know in
New England it's all you know it's in
the high 80s we should have had a frost
by now we're nowhere near that so I
think people see obviously the climate
is changing it's no longer very subtle
I'm afraid have you come across any
ideas as to how we might more
effectively communicate with so-called
climate skeptics or deniers of science
we know from the research done by folks
like Daniel Kahneman for example that
just sort of beating people over the
head with facts does not really seem to
be too effective in bringing people over
and sort of predisposing them to want to
take action is there like a patriotic
appeal
that could be made maybe a national
security appeal that you've thought of I
mean what what might be a better
approach to try to build consensus well
I think that as you say the thrust of a
lot of social science research over the
last twenty thirty years has been yeah
you can give people as much information
practical objective information as you
want and it doesn't really change their
mind once their identity is sort of tied
up we believe in one thing or another
and I think that many people have
concluded therefore and so we're in this
kind of interesting standoff that you
know people you know people like me the
media you know even politicians on the
left even you know are not going to or
unless you know center-left whatever are
not going to be the ones who are going
to be able to reach people who is
political identities or cultural
identities and are now tied up with
denying that climate change exists that
the messengers are going to have to
change religious figures generals all of
those right-wing talk-show hosts you
know all those are potentially people
who could change this conversation but
they have to want to change the
conversation well what would make them
want to I guess is the question right
that is exactly what we're waiting for
that is what we're waiting for and I if
I had that answer you know I'd be out
there trying to make it happen that
there is this kind of like inherent
optimism that exists in some people who
say we don't need to worry about this
and I'm not talking about those who say
God would never have set up a planet
that we could damage right I'm not
talking about that view I'm talking very
specifically about the view which is I'm
not worried about this because humans
are smart and resourceful and will
always stay slightly ahead of it
actually becoming a crisis how do you
communicate with someone like that and
explain to them that the crisis is now
that we're seeing more you know heat
related deaths among the very young and
elder
than we've seen for a long time whether
of that whatever argument you can make
how can you explain that this is already
sort of outpacing human ingenuity well I
think that what people really need to
appreciate with climate change and why
climate scientists have really been
trying desperately to issue these
warnings is that there's a tremendous
amount of inertia in the climate system
and it's not the case that you can say
and the nursery springs from a few
different directions as it were first of
all they're still warming in the
pipeline so even if we just really
stopped emitting co2 basically tomorrow
which you know evidently we're not going
to do there's still a lot of warming
left in the system until the climate
reaches a new equilibrium and I'm not
going to go into the kind of geophysics
of that but it's pretty basic science um
and so what you're seeing what you see
out your window the idea that okay when
it gets really bad we'll fix it
that is simply in this case
unfortunately not possible because
you've already set things in motion that
you can't get back this is why
scientists are so worried for example is
the Antarctic West Antarctic ice sheets
starting to disintegrate because once
you set that in motion there's a lot of
inertia in that system and you're not
going to get that back
so that's one reason why we really need
to be proactive as opposed to reactive
another reason is obviously just that
energy systems take a long time to
convert you know it's very very
difficult to our whole economy the
entire world economy of basically for
all intents and purposes right now runs
on fossil fuels if you want to change
that which evidently we have to you've
got to get going and you've got to get
started and you can't expect it to
happen tomorrow so there's a lot of
inertia in that system as well and when
you sort of you know add together all
these forms of inertia you realize that
we really needed to start this process a
long long time ago is there anything
you're seeing that makes you at all
optimistic and it could be either at the
you know micro level at a more macro
level it could be you know
Changez we're seeing in China or India
that are slowly moving away from fossil
fuels as the soul sort of provider of
energy even though it's happening
relatively slowly something that you
know a private company like Tesla is
doing we've had seven or eight countries
in Europe that have said over the next
10 or 20 years they want to get all
fossil fuel using vehicles off the roads
I mean it all sort of feels like they're
not really the strongest commitment they
could be changed if it ends up not being
that convenient and even still it's it
might end up being sort of too little
too late I mean is there something to be
optimistic about well I think that those
are the wrong you know those are sort of
the wrong categories that we keep
looking for some I think one of the
other problems that we have in dealing
with climate changes that we keep
looking for some answer there's going to
be one answer that's going to sort of
silver bullet and it's just not that
kind of a problem you're going to need a
million different answers but I do think
the one hopeful development I suppose
you could say is you know the really
really radical decline in the price of
solar power so that there are now times
of day in certain parts of the country
certain parts of the world where you
know basically are giving away power and
once that happens there's a lot of
things you know that you can do with
that power that might be really useful
like you know charge your electric car
and things like that so I think that
that is a very positive development and
one thing that it's show is if you talk
to it experts is that you know that
didn't just happen
that happened because there were a lot
of entities including you know the
Chinese government and the German
government which put a lot of money into
solar power and what's known as feed-in
tariffs where you basically utilities
had to buy solar power all these things
you know that I won't get into the too
bogged down in the bureaucratic details
but a lot of lot of effort on the part
of a lot of Governors governments and
also entrepreneurs went into this and we
need that on many many different fronts
so that unfortunately brings us back to
the current administration which is
actually you know
the budget just slashed R&D on a lot of
these programs which is obviously
exactly a long way to go yeah I mean
along those lines at face value at the
30,000 foot level it seems well one
thing that should happen is government
should stop subsidizing oil in the
production of gasoline and instead put
those subsidies towards renewable energy
is it that simple would that make a big
difference that would make a huge
difference I think people don't really
appreciate you know how many tax once
again we don't we don't see them unless
you're in the know oil industry the coal
industry you don't know where the tax
breaks are but they're huge and people
have compiled them and those amounts to
government subsidies and when you
compile them they're in that you know I
can't remember the you know hundreds of
billions of dollars if their I don't
remember what the figures are but
they're very very high and if we took
all that you know that pot of money
which is basically a pot of missing
revenues and we put it toward you know
you took it away from things that we
don't want and put it towards things
that we do want I don't want to say it
would solve the problem but it would go
it would be a huge step in the right
direction let's put it that way
we've been speaking with Elizabeth
Kolbert she writes for The New Yorker
also author of the book the sixth
extinction which I recommend highly to
the audience Elizabeth thank you so much
for talking to us about this thanks for
having me